okay guys in the last house we were
releasing you from the balcony but now
you get the whole front door experience
is three - good morning today's the big
move day so as you can see we didn't
quite finish the closets last night
Casey and I were up until like 2:00 a.m.
trying to finish as much as we could at
least I got my vanity area done and
Isaac packed up his entire room right
now he's handling the kiddies I got you
Maya
you gotta stay in there Maya what
happened Isaac I'm not ready
well you squished your head no are you
okay baby yeah Australia not let her in
so and then I did that and then boom
it's okay we got her out he's a tough
one
she is a toughy yeah so we're trying to
keep the cat's outside of the balcony Oh
cute you're trying to keep them on the
balcony because the movers have just
gotten here they're starting to move
some furniture there's still like I said
there's a lot of things we got to do
like all these drawers it's only gonna
be cleared out lots of things to still
pack but the good news is the entire
kitchen is done the entire living room
was done our game plan for today is half
the movers move all the big furniture
stuff and whatever boxes we were able to
box up just anything huge that won't fit
in our car or we're just gonna have them
take Oh Maya is spicy everything else
we're gonna just be boxing up ourselves
and just moving in our own cars once
we're done with the movers because like
tomorrow we're having our walkthrough
with the landlord but I think we're
altima Taliah gonna add end up asking
for one more day to finish clearing
everything else out then we're going to
the new house we're finally getting
closer to that moment this one like that
sweet sweet moment when everything's
unboxed and you're just chilling and
your brand-new plate all the decor is up
and it just feels like a complete home
closer to that feeling I still feel like
we still live you're useless in
renovating this this scene right here
reminds me of the very first memory that
I can recollect right here - really
cause I mean we're moving we put the
cans yeah but then we were also vlogging
it that's why it's so fresh in my mind
yeah and then like and then after we're
done moving at night tower it's like
lighting like cats in there like enjoy
your new house yeah I know which room
are we gonna keep them in the new house
laundry room I said I'm thinking I drew
one so from the laundry room out yes now
the new scene the sequel the downstairs
bedroom so they could start from the
bottom
oh you're right I like that plan better
actually cuz then there's no possibility
of like carpets getting dirty what are
you packing what's your game plan did as
much as you could downstairs not too
tired to do that stairs stuff last night
so now we got the other stuff they're
gonna have their own system the movers
and they just got here big pieces like
the bed need to go sooner I think then
later mm-hmm but I was trying to like
look new and well their truck can't fit
underneath into her garage apartment
complex where the last one never far
from the street oh man that sucks it
sucks for them because they have to
exert more energy and work harder which
really sucks but then I can't help but
think about it sucks for us too because
we're paying them how early it's gonna
take them longer true for them and to
get to the good thing - is it true more
time yeah yeah more money who the cats
those like why are you locking us out
here mommy
why mommy why sorry my boy but little do
you know but you're gonna have a new
home by the end of
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we first moved in to put this Glock yes
please showcase how dumb I am
it was the most idiotic decision of my
life so I put like this filter to kind
of like make it what's the word frosted
yes blackness so it could be like
frosted cotton yeah the dumbest thing I
could have done was putting it on the
outside of the glass or even on the
inside well now that I'm removing it I
assume it should be it's supposed to be
on the inside because of all the the
rain and like the water on it now it's
it's rusted and it has like glued on to
the glass so right now I'm like oh no
how are we gonna remove this and I wish
I could go back in time and put it on
the inside well it sounds like an heizak
job all of this up here that was not wet
so easy to remove but because I put it
there since Sun the Sun is baking on
that what's the with the witness and the
Sun is force listing oh yeah I don't
throw it just like save stay some in
your hand and then throw it inside I'm
gonna try to find something where you
can treat it I don't want him to scratch
it scratch the window so we already have
- okay - recarpet the master bedroom and
the hallway because our cats destroyed
the carpet and then now I'm thinking
we're carving out that it's gonna have
to pay to get a new glass - we're not
getting our deposit back
oh no no
that's kinda cute though
it's a cute if that's a cute thousand
dollars or spending somewhere between
like 500 and like 900 because of that
one patch that's been recorded and all
this in here is getting recarpet 'add
alright so I had to kind of work around
genius boy genius boy I'm taking a break
it's a vlog break guys and an 85 degrees
break the bed is gone you look so lonely
in like alone here's an update hey it
looks like a map of the United States
upside down maybe not I don't know not
that this is Lord of I realized it needs
to be over here I don't know how's it
going oh you spent a lot of time doing
that was it hard
Oh adhesive tape remover and that's
helping a lot yeah so today we realized
we're just gonna be moving all the big
stuff there's a lot of little stuff that
I still needs to be moving the mover
said that their truck is capacity almost
there so priority things that we're
trying to move basically is all big
furniture pieces that we can't move
unless we have a big truck all the
little things that we can just stuff in
our cars we'll probably do it tomorrow
yeah and I think we're just talking
about how cool it's gonna be tonight
because tonight will be the first time
we're doing everything first time
sleeping at the new house first time
eating something at the new house first
time oh yeah we did I did a Valentine's
Day post where we went to the house to
eat oh cos like that that time didn't
have lights it it was just dark we were
just sitting in the dark we brought a
camping lantern to eat but this time
we'll have light and no table first
times P pooping yeah just first time and
everything yeah we haven't actually
spent a whole lot of time like that at
the new house I always feel like I'm
visiting the house I'm not really like
living there so today will be the first
of all those things you got all our
clothes oh we didn't get a chance to
load this stuff up man tip has a lot of
clothes makes my site that's all TIFF
stuff my side effects
yeah like three bags mommy has like a
quadrant quadrillion just to yours looks
like your pole is about the snap
you know how mommy snapped her Pole yeah
yeah you're something it's gonna do that
let's take a look out downstairs
[Music]
the laundry's done so the kitchen is
missing the fridge our old dining area
is gone now we have these plants that
were I think they're gonna take in the
car later and this is our living room
that it's completely empty our front
yard still looks the same
alright we are now oh now we're just
waiting on the movers pretty soon this
will no longer be echoey
oh yeah we're gonna break the new house
smell a momentous occasion the very
first box
they're all cups in the garage we have
everything we still need to sell and get
rid of you want to try the candy dried
scallops like some Chinese like you
throw this in your soups if you're
making like a wok or whatever it's very
delicious dandy all right we just got
back to the old house we're gonna do one
last trip one last run we're gonna try
and pack up our cars as much as possible
because tomorrow aunt is so kind and he
said he will let us borrow his
forerunner and also his help him as
himself and so tomorrow we're really
gonna just get everything to get out but
in the meantime since we aren't going
back home cuz we have to come back to
pick up the kitty cats so since we're
here and I needed to pick up my car -
might as well pack up the car
oh man they're cold and zelgadis calling
me she so picked out this room looks
crazy what where are we this is not a
room I know alright we are now back at
the new place we have unloaded the cars
but we have not introduced the house to
the cats yet oh my gosh Isaac I need to
tell the vlog how frickin shoot you were
the entire right over here it was so
adorable so where was though he liked
that and then he kept meowing and
freaking out right and what were you
doing you're so good and so patient you
were just like this is so cute
because yeah you kept like calming him
down you're like it's okay so we're
gonna be there in like 20 minutes
don't even worry are you with me now are
you with me like it was so cute
serious together Oh like oh my god I got
a glimpse into him being into being a
big brother it was a cutest thing ever
unleash the beast who's that Maya Maya
are you ready to see your new house so
come on
okay guys in the last house we were
releasing you from the balcony right you
wanna do the honors Isaac of course you
do
[Music]
you but now you get the whole front door
experience in 3 2 1
there has turned the exact same time how
cute they're like my this is where are
we
hey so does not waste time yeah he's the
brave one my is a little more careful
look at him he's exploring like Oh cute
yeah where are we tell this is our new
home I wanna leave here Maya we're home
this is our new place my they're like
where's the carpet smells familiar
and the other stuff is oh you like their
stairs here too there's stairs here it's
like nah hold on I gotta get a feel out
of this place first he's like I
recognize this that's familiar that's
that we're supposed to be yeah like
what's going on here recognize anything
you like I know that chair I love seeing
those figure it out that there's an
upstairs they could go up there my
[Music]
you're like okay hold on let me get the
lay of the land you're getting the lay
of the land
Maya I'm kur liar it's so cute
I think so no he's at work and I hide so
you care about how Maya's oh hi Maya do
you like our new place Oh your favorite
Maya she figured it out she likes going
behind the couch oh my god I love this
so much
[Music]
Maya's already like that's it I'm not
moving out of this oh wait where she go
she likes this spot this little corner
she feels safe there yeah because she's
like secluded you ready to go yeah he's
going up you ready though let's go see
up here she's so excited oh what's up
here what's up here
what's going on in here you recognize
that he's like well this carpet feels
different look she's walking funny
Isaac's room with the Hello Kitty
blanket yeah it's just so soft Maya Maya
you're gonna come up Maya
Maya come here come here Maya she's way
too freaked out she was like no no no I
haven't even gone downstairs yet so it
was like way more adventurous he's like
okay I think I got this I scoped it out
and scope out the place let's go check
out the next level oh yeah my is way too
scary
she's so cute so timid oh now he's in
the office how cute he's checking out
the neighborhood she was looking at the
Oscar she was looking outside the window
like yeah he's like he really is he was
like okay alright okay he's rubbing
himself a guys everything juries like
it's breaking this man yeah he's like
this is my house now this is where I'm
gonna live alright pretty much been
eight years eight years no one knows how
long he's like all right I got upstairs
upstairs down the way and I get that
corner
I don't sing music right got it
social system right it feels like my you
gotta check it out I already spoke about
the place and they say it's okay maybe
that's why he pretty spread his scent
everywhere is for Maya he's being a good
good brother
he's like oh maybe she'll feel safe if I
spread my scent everyone going on what's
going on what's going on do you want to
come upstairs this is a cutest thing
ever seeing them explore new spaces
because ever since they were born
they've only ever been in a handful of
places so it's like the house where they
were born
so that our first apartment together and
then the second place that we got to go
the place we just left and then now this
house so literally only six places in
their entire life have they ever visited
so bringing them to a new space is a big
deal hey he likes the place do you
approve you approve that was you saying
you approve yeah
QED oh my god cute so are you happy
you're spreading your scent everywhere
especially me you're like this is my
mommy my mommy is here window time all
right we are winding down for the night
it was been a very very eventful day and
we're eating some leftover Papa John's
seal up the windows yes no more people
spying on us not that anyone was spying
on us to begin with but just feels a
little more cozier I was telling Isaac
that we were living the American dream
mm-hmm because we have two plates
microwave yeah maybe we should microwave
a longer longer clothes you that is
beauty all right and we are celebrating
tonight with some drinks I never had
this before angry orchard with the green
apple one that's kind of exciting no I
had a crispy apple they have a different
they have different flavors I guess
you're turning up with this it was some
apple cider of your own yeah all right
to a new home new life whoa whoa you
replacing your few places
oh yeah cuz this experience has made
it's grown into new people is that what
you're saying yeah oh yeah
this place so true I honestly feel like
I'm flying to hit me until I make the
first mortgage payment look we already
paid for the down payment but I keep
telling myself like that when I was
getting this food and drinks driving
through the streets I was like huh just
thinking you know by I see you guys
tomorrow
with ants we're gonna be moving some
more stuff and it would be so tired
because it's already late now and we're
gonna wake up early tomorrow and oh yeah
we got a crazy guy you got a crazy guy
taking our stuff in the morning I'm
what's going on here what are you doing
here I'm taking what I can so I could
sell it all make the most money
oh really I have two kids so I need a
feat did we get his percentage I have a
kid a few two as you can see don't they
okay - thank you No
[Music]